so you're back in Star Trek now but like  over all the time you haven't been doing  it the show as you guys are saying never  goes away it's constantly on television  do you ever find yourself like drawn  into watching them I don't look for it  but occasionally you know you're and  there was one night in a hotel somewhere  I'd flown in I had room ordered room  service and I was flicking to you and  that was Oh Star Trek next generation  okay let's see what's going on I'll just  watch it for a couple of minutes  well I got hooked and then there was a  ring of the doorbell and my my order  arrived my room service order arrived  and the waiter came in looked at me and  I thought he's gonna go away and tell  the entire kitchen it is the saddest  thing  [Laughter]  [Music]